foreign
[Music]
four thousand laboratory Associated
infections have endangered the health of
laboratory workers
the majority of these cases occurred in
people engaged in research or clinical
diagnostic work
the people involved were primarily
trained laboratory professionals
eighty percent of the hazards
investigated resulted from unknown
causes
[Music]
ever droplet nuclei and large droplet
aerosols created during laboratory
procedures have been recognized as
principal sources of contamination
whether a laboratory worker becomes
infected depends on several factors
these include the extent of
contamination
root of infection
virulence of the organism and host
susceptibility
[Music]
the problem is compounded by the
unnecessary generation of aerosols when
common laboratory tools the inoculating
loop
pipette
syringe and needle
are used incorrectly
procedures requiring a blender or
centrifuge may result in the production
of infectious aerosols and contamination
of working surfaces
using a properly maintained blender
centrifuge and biological safety cabinet
will minimize infection
in this presentation
we will explore how to properly use and
maintain these pieces of equipment
[Music]
animal studies play a major role in some
areas of microbiology such as mycology
and virology
often in these studies animals must be
necropsied and the microbial populations
in organs Quantified
these procedures may result in the
production of infectious aerosols
animal organs must often be homogenized
the risks during homogenization may be
minimized by proper use of the high
speed blender
a household blender should not be used
to homogenize tissue
the loose cover will release many
droplet nuclei aerosols into the air
this is an unnecessary danger because
aerosol-free blenders are available
a properly functioning aerosol-free
blender gives excellent protection from
infectious aerosols
but bearings in the cutting blade shaft
should be regularly inspected and
replaced when worn
always inspect the O-ring seal or rubber
gasket
a damaged gasket permits aerosols to be
released
the aerosol free blender is equipped
with a closed drainage system to drain
the contents
when you bypass this closed system and
immediately remove the cover and aerosol
is released
remember violent agitation generated by
the cutting blades causes aerosols which
remain suspended within the blender for
over an hour after it has stopped
precautions must also be taken when
working with a centrifuge
you can minimize the likelihood of
droplet nuclei being released from
broken tubes by doing the following
first inspect each tube to be used
be certain there are no chips or cracks
now inspect the carriers in the
centrifuge head
be sure carriers are clean and that
mountings are secure
then balance specimens on opposite sides
of the centrifuge head
balancing will reduce vibration and
stress thus minimizing the possibility
of breakage
cap and seal each safety carrier
carefully
finally replace the centrifuge cover and
make sure that it is secure
we have used a bucket type centrifuge
with safety carriers to demonstrate
these procedures
before beginning work with an angle head
centrifuge
first inspect each tube for defects as
previously demonstrated
do not fill tubes to the top because the
contents will spill when the tubes are
placed at an angle in the centrifuge
you must also balance paired carriers
and seal each carrier
the last step is to securely close the
centrifuge cover
as you see the same step-by-step
procedure is followed with the bucket
type and the angle head centrifuge The
Only Exception is in limiting tube
contents to prevent spillage in the
angle head centrifuge
under certain conditions aerosols May
escape from a tube during high speed
rotation
the most dangerous situation occurs when
a tube shatters in the centrifuge Shield
released microorganisms have been
detected up to 12 or more feet from the
centrifuge
we have examined the formation of
droplet nuclei in procedures performed
with common laboratory equipment
some procedures generate large droplets
larger than 5 microns
these particles are airborne for a short
time and then settle on the skin and
bench tops
these large droplets usually cannot
penetrate beyond the tracheobronchial
tree
surface contamination can result from
separating the halves of a petri dish
a moisture film may form between two
contact points
when the film is broken aerosol droplets
develop
contamination can also result from the
surface film breaking when screw top
tubes are opened
additionally surface contamination may
result when supernatants are decanted
this happens when a solution is poured
into another container and large aerosol
droplets form
as we have seen large droplets May
settle on any surface in the laboratory
remember
droplet nuclei which are smaller May
drift over considerable distances
they may then settle out and contaminate
surfaces
aerosols cannot always be eliminated but
their effects can be minimized through
use of a biological safety cabinet
the biological safety cabinet when used
in conjunction with good microbiological
technique provides a safe environment
for the laboratory worker
this negative pressure or class 1 unit
is one type of safety cabinet
another type of safety cabinet is the
laminar flow or class II cabinet
the negative pressure cabinet is usually
four to six feet wide
a glass plate is located between the
laboratorian and the work
the cabinet is equipped with an access
opening through which most items may be
placed in the working area
larger items can be introduced by
raising the hinged glass plate
air is drawn through the front opening
by a blower at a velocity of 75 linear
feet per minute
the effluent air from the cabinet must
be decontaminated to protect people
Downstream
in this model high efficiency
particulate air filters called HEPA
filters are located above the work area
they are designed to retain
99.99 percent of particles three tenths
of a micron in diameter
as an additional Safeguard an
ultraviolet light is mounted above the
HEPA filter
the ultraviolet Source provides lethal
radiation for any particulate matter
escaping the HEPA filters
room air is drawn through the front
opening of the cabinet
the air moves with such velocity that
dust-borne microorganisms are unlikely
to contaminate the culture media in use
the microbiologist should handle both
media and equipment so as to minimize
introducing contaminants into the media
always place a towel soaked in
disinfectant over the immediate work
area
this will reduce aerosols created by
splatters
open flasks or test tubes should be held
at a 45 degree angle with the open end
facing inward
this avoids directing unwanted microbes
into the culture medium
when opening a petried dish the cover
should be tilted back toward the
operator
this serves as a protective shield
further reducing the possibility of
contaminating the culture medium
the laminar flow cabinet and negative
pressure cabinet are similar in
dimension and construction
the laminar flow cabinet recirculates 80
to 90 percent of its air through HEPA
filters
the result is a cleaner working area for
the microbiologist
for this reason the blower must be
turned on at least five minutes before
work is begun
this will establish the air barrier and
Purge the working area
the 10 to 20 percent of error drawn into
the front provides an air barrier
this barrier limits the number of room
contaminants reaching the work area and
virtually eliminates the movement of
pathogens back into the room
air drawn into the front opening of the
laminar flow cabinet is equal in volume
to that exhausted
the exhausted air goes through HEPA
filters prior to discharge into the room
or an exhaust duct
ideally however the cabinet exhaust air
should not be recirculated
to ensure protective functioning of the
laminar flow cabinet
Place equipment and supplies in the
cabinet before beginning work
make sure that intake and exhaust
grilles are not covered
even when working in a cabinet you
should practice aseptic techniques
since much of the air is recirculated
heat can build up
for this reason use open Flames as
little as possible
several recommendations apply to both
negative pressure and laminar flow
cabinets
before using any safety cabinet become
thoroughly familiar with the operator's
manual
where are protective clothing and
maintain a clean working environment
next position the glass partition
between you and the working area
be sure the blower is on and working
before using the cabinet
perform all work well inside the cabinet
area
when work in the cabinet is completed
clean and decontaminate all exposed
surfaces
be certain that the ultraviolet light is
turned on at all times except while you
are working in the cabinet
each ultraviolet light bulb should be
periodically cleaned and checked for
efficiency
a final word of caution
never use a safety cabinet as a
substitute for a chemical fume Hood
infectious hazards may be minimized by
using safe laboratory procedures
these procedures include proper handling
of common laboratory tools
attention to detail in operating
laboratory equipment
and proper use of biological safety
cabinets
[Music]